the White House
wants to take away your beer they want
to limit you to two beers per week Dr
George Coop who is the director of the
National Institute of alcohol abuse and
alcoholism says the U.S May soon follow
Canada and recommend just two beers a
week how do you guys think that's gonna
go let me tell you what I'm not gonna
get involved in in uh in that in that
question right there I I have no idea
I've not seen the data I cannot speak to
this I will leave it to the experts this
is a great exchange not because of the
beer thing who cares no one's going to
follow this advice probably had too many
beers but because of what it tells you
about the experts and what the
conservatives think about the experts
and even what the Liberals think about
the experts